hello everyone if I speak a little funny
it is because I just came back from the
dentists and I don't really feel the
left side of my face but I I hope it'll
be okay this next game was played in
1966 it was a tournament in Hastings and
we have a game between William Hudson
and a world-renowned Grandmaster a set
of Glee voyage and William Harrison here
he was a PhD student he was a seventeen
years old at the time this game was
played and later in 1972 he got his
international master title the highest
rating he ever got was twenty four
hundred and eighty five and he almost
became a grandmaster but never did and
he retired from chess later in 1985 I
believe 1987 and he now he's mostly
known as a chess promoter on TV and and
the chest author but while this game was
played this is around seven and William
lost the first five rounds in this
tournament he drew drew round six and
this is round seven he's playing against
Seto's of legal age and before I show
you the game I would just like to say
that a pedia article about William
Hudson says that he was able to stack an
entire chess set pieces from the entire
chess set on top of a single rook now
this I mean if this is true that's quite
an accomplishment you know aside from
being a a PhD student being almost a
grandmaster he's also quite quite the
architect so that being said let's see
this game
Hudson has the white pieces and he plays
efore c5 the Sicilian Knight to f3 d6 d4
C capture son d4 Knight captures and the
knight to f6 Knight to c3
we have a6 the knight or variation
Bishop to g5 & e6 we have f4 by Hartson
and this is a well-known position in
those days everyone in the world played
this position black has a lot of options
here
he can play h6 he can go Bishop e7 he
can go tonight bt7
but there was a one variation that was
extremely popular back then and it's
called the poisoned pawn variation and
that's exactly what the licorice goes
for that's the Queen to b6 move now
threatening the B to pawn and white will
usually play a Queen d2 which was played
in the game will give up the pawn for
some rapid development but if you're
playing against the friend you know who
likes to play the poisoned pawn a
variation you can always try this a3
idea and now if your friend captures the
pawn on be to simply Knight a four and
his queen is trapped if it's not a
serious game if it is a serious game
don't maybe not go for a three
so after Queen to b6 we have Queen to d2
by Hartson giving up the B to pawn Queen
captures and now rook the b1 if you've
seen my video of round 11 of the famous
match Bobby Fischer vs Boris Spassky
Boris Spassky here played Knight to b3
it's that game you have it on my channel
it's called crime and punishment and
Spassky really destroys Fischer in this
one it's a quite a lovely miniature do
check it out if you haven't
but the the spot special game was played
six games after six years after this
game so Spassky had time to prepare some
new poisons but in this game a rook to
be one was played which was standard
Queen to a 3 and now f5 and this is
still all standard theory Knight to c6 f
captures any 6 F captors any six-night
captures on c6 b captures on c6 and now
e5 threatening the knight on f6 we have
d captures on f5 and now Bishop captures
on f6 breaking open the Kings defense G
captures on f6 and Knight to e4 and this
is a very interesting line now that
occurs in here
settlers played Bishop to e7 as this f6
pawn is attacked while actually the
strongest move is capturing the pawn on
a2 but this requires a whole lot of
calculation and if you're not familiar
familiar with the line
you're probably not gonna go for it over
the board because after Queen captures
on a2 and if white plays Knight captures
on f6 would check
King to f7 and now black is attacking
both the knight on f6 and the rook on b1
but the problem here is white has this
rook to b3 move and this is what the
black had to calculate over the border
it was okay to capture the pawn and a2
but it's not okay to capture tonight on
f6 white has to play Queen to e1 with
check because if you capture the knight
on f6 you get checkmate it and it's
forced checkmate in seven moves Queen to
d8 check Bishop to e7 Queen captures
rook with check King g6 Queen g8 king of
five Queen captures on h7 check King f6
now rook comes to f3 with the check out
King goes g5 h for checking g4 and Queen
to g6 check bishop passed the block and
Queen captures on g5 this is checkmate
and even if you don't after Queen to d8
if you don't block with the bishop if
you play something like King the g7
doesn't really help you simply erupted
the g3 immediately king f7 Rock f3 check
King chief g6 and now Queen to f6 check
King goes to h5 rakesh 3 check King g4
and Bishop to e2 this is checkmate so if
you're not familiar with all of this
you're probably not going to capture
this pawn over the board
so Bishop d7 was plainly go to defense d
f6 pawn we have Bishop to e2 and now
again Glico rich castles in this
position while I'm probably a more
resilient move would be h5 and this is
something that often happens when white
plays Bishop to e2 and the threatens to
play Bishop to h5 then h5 is in most
cases ok but okay after Bishop to e2
blue got rich played King side castle
Carson castles and queen to a4 now
attacking the knight on e4 grabbing the
pawn is there's really no point in doing
this rugby 3 again
comes into play so see for now blocking
the Queen's attack to the Knight f5
attacking the knight and here we have
that move that we already discussed rook
to b3 and okay it's an interesting
position glitch played c5 he decided to
play c5 to play to be able to bring the
Queen back into the defense of course
capturing the knight would fail terribly
because of rook the g3 check at King h8
now rook captures special characters and
queen to g5 and there is no defense
against Queen to g8 checkmate
or if you pull the pond and Queen to g8
and then going to g6 checkmate so after
rugby 3 garage played c5 Queen to h6 and
this was I mean it's a still great
position for white but hearts and missed
an insta-kill here a better move would
have been instead of this Queen to h6
rope the g3 check immediately and now if
you play King to have 7 Bishop to h5 is
checkmate and if you don't if you play
King to h8 then you get Queen to c3 and
white is threatening to capture the e5
pawn and there is no defense against
this and checkmate of course he can play
Bishop f6 but simply Knight captures and
after we capture screen captures on e5
and again there is no defense against
Queen captures rook and checkmate
so after this c5 move hearts and played
Queen to h6 and okay it's still a better
position rook to f7 we have rook to g3
with check King to h8 Bishop to h5 now
attacking the rook on f7 and it's you
can't really move that rook if you move
the rook then Queen to g7 is checkmate
so Queen to e8 now defending the bishop
and here we have a beautiful move by
William Hartson rook captures an f5 now
threatening this rook with a double
threat of rook captures and Bishop
captures so it characters on f5 black
captures rook and now Knight to d6
sacrificing the night after
now the night is attacking the Queen and
the rook so Bishop captures on d6 was
played and here we have Bishop captures
on f7 and in this position set was
illegally to resigned the game it
doesn't really matter what black plays
it all it's the checkmate if Bishop
capped if Queen captures Bishop and f7
add then Queen captures on d6 and here
you have that problem from move 20 you
can't defend this ePHI pawn so whatever
black plays h5 for example simply Queen
h6 now even faster Queen blocks Czech
Queen d7 and Queen captures on g7 is
checkmate and after Bishop to f7 if
something like Queen to f8 then simply
Queen captures better captures and rope
to g8
and this is checkmate so I have to be up
to 7 SS or legally to resign the game
and a beautiful masterpiece in the
poisoned pawn variation was achieved
even if it could have been achieved
sooner if if rook to g3 was played on
move 20 but okay you know it's very nice
as it is and I would also like to say
that I didn't really show any gains by
circly great so far I did show that one
game the immortal back house game but I
will eventually do a series of legal age
and you know really show everyone what a
beast he was so yeah that's the game I
do hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank rajesh khattar oil man hunty Buca
bottom
alan adds Barry Allen Asbury and Ricardo
Prado for contribution to my channel
thank you a lot - really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here and I think all for watching
and I'll see you soon and hopefully a
lot of you tomorrow on the stream see
you soon